qu'ils ne pourront jamais payé
ses loyers la. Julie Marceau
nous en parle.
- Demain je vous écoute chaque
personne...
- C'est jour de classe
de francisation.
sont dsont dsont dsont dsont dse
ou des réfugiés. Ils préfèrent
ne pas s'identifier.
Mais ils tiennent à dire que
le cours est important, même sÉx
nouveaux arrivants (CANA)
Centre communautaire Ahuntsic
- Comme ci comme ça...
Étudiant
(rires)rtant
(...) pour m'intégrer
à la société québécoise.
- Ces cours sont donnés
au centre communautaire
du quartier Ahuntsic.
L'immeub
- Si on va par ici, on arrive
au Carrefour d'aide aux nouve ax
arrivants qui est au 2e étage.
- Rémy Robitaille coordonne
les différents serrts
dans l'immeuble.
l'un des rares guichet unique
communautaire à Montréal.
C'est-à-dire que tout est
Ainsi un parent migrant
peut suivre un cou
de francisation au 3e étage,
faire garder son enfant
à la halte-garder
plus bas, tout en passant
à la banque alimentaire
pour récsol. le propriétaire
du bâtiment, le Centre de
services scolaire de Montréal
de loyer de 222% depuis 2018.ent
: la facture totale s'élève
à 750 000 dollars en hausse en e
impayée de loyer.
Rémy Robitaille est responsat re
des baux pour tout le monde.
r, Solidarite Ahuntsic
- Donc, ça veut soit dire
une failune failune failune fair
tous déménager, il y aura
une rupture de service- Le probe
d'argent pour financer
les écoles.
Résultat : Québec,par l'entremis
de services scolaires, effectues
dits excédentaires...
d'anciennes écoles louées
au milieu communautairetairetaie
comme ici.
Conséquence : les loyers
augmentesus de vente
s'amorce parallèlement.
Les employés de la
alimentaire, qui ont vu leur
clientèle doubler,
n'en reviennent pas.
Nutrition, actcommunautaire SNAC
- Ça va être catastroph
on doit être relocalisés
ailleurs ou si on doit partir...
je... il faut trou
de stockage, l'espace
de distribution.
ELISABETH OLIVIER, Prof.,
Carrefour d'aide i
- C'est tout un monde qui
s'écroule dans cet édifice-là...
et tous
- Le Ministère de l'éducation
renvoit la balle arerererererere
dans ce dossier. Il s'est limité
à nous dire avoir à coeur
d'éviter une rupture de service
sans vouloir commenter la ha
salée de loyer ou le processus
de ventement.ment.ment.ment.ment
un projet de centre
le futur
quartier Louvain est, mais elle
a besoin d'argent et de temps.E,
arron. d'Ahuntsic-Cartierville
- Nous, ce qu'on demandec'est de
qu'on puisse se coordonner pourt
par exemple prêt avant que
les organismes de solidarité
Ahuntsic soient miporteportepore
de là ou ils sont en ce moment.l
à la collaboration, alors quelea
des années et des millions
de dollars.
Radio-Canada, Mo